this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your mental health your
relationships and your money
i'm john dalone joined here by my good
friend george campbell and we are taking
your calls on everything
lines are open triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go to anna in
san jose california hey anna what's up
hello just looking for some help on
strategy oh your name is anna isn't it
anna yes it is thank you here's the
thing you said it right
and jenna wrote it correctly it's her
name oh that's true well played you said
it right
uh jen jenna the call screener she wrote
it correctly and i didn't read it i'm
sorry i hate getting people's names
wrong that's so basic humanity so anna
what's up
okay my husband and i want to purchase a
home
and we're hoping to be able to pay cash
for that but we just
have a little bit of a struggle on
strategy on what we should do first
we currently are renting we live in san
jose california the ranch is outrageous
we have four hundred thousand dollars
towards a house purchase we realize that
we'll have to move out of the area
my husband and i are both working right
now we would not be able to transfer
over our jobs if we leave the state
so that means looking for new employment
as well
he has contact in the dallas area that
he feels he could secure a job
but there's a high
income are the high property taxes in
dallas so we were also looking in
florida but he doesn't really have that
many contacts there
additionally we have a 103 year old
mother-in-law in a nursing home
and that means leaving her and then
coming back for her later to bring her
to where we're at so we just don't know
what step like should we look for the
house first or look for the job first or
what where do you guys want to live
um well ideally in a perfect world i'd
love to stay in san jose because
we were both born and raised but we know
that we can't do that
so he's looking he's leaning towards
dallas because of the job
contact i'm leaning towards florida
because we'd be on the coast close to
the water what we're used to how old are
you guys and um
uh we're all
we're old souls i am uh 66 and he's 65.
but we want to keep working we're both
very healthy and we're young 65 and 66.
so i i
love the fact that you want to keep
working i think that's remarkable
i want you to think
you're 65 67.
george's question i don't want you to
miss how poignant that was
what do you want to do
because you're asking questions as
though you're at the beginning of your
financial future i want to avoid this i
want to
you're in the you've worked hard to get
where you are
so what do you want to do
we want to ideally we want to be home
owners and we don't want to have a
mortgage
so that when we do stop working whenever
that is
we are secure that we have you know
shelter and room over our over our head
we have no debt no credit cards no car
payments none of that
so your question
sounds like it's coming from a place of
fear
that if soon yeah everything's going to
implode and we need to make sure we've
got a tent and a lean to
and like a root cellar
and i want to flip this around you've
said you got hundred thousand dollars
yeah in cash
yeah
that will buy you a nice place in a lot
of places across the country
not in not in san jose not in california
not in certain not in austin not in
certain parts of florida that's a chunk
of money
and so i would love you to flip this
thing around and say we were born and
raised here we spent all of our life
here we want one last adventure
where do we want to go and not look at
it as you're escaping
for your lives but you are going to live
your life the fullest and i know i know
you're leaving california so i know many
people think they are escaping with
their lives but do you get what i'm
saying how important that mindset shift
is
yeah because when you make a when you
make such a big move out of fear and
desperation you end up in a city you
don't want to be in or you don't think
through all the implications or you wish
you had just been on the water and you
kind of regret the last 10 years
i want you to flip that thing around and
say we get to because we've been
stewards of our money because we have
put ourselves in a position where we
want to still be working we are blessed
with health
what do we want to do we got 10 15 years
of working years left we want to go to
the wheels fall off on this thing what
do we want to do with that
and start thinking about that and then
this whole thing turns into an exciting
adventure not a run run
you get that
what's interesting is that you you were
to have a paid for house but then you
are worried about the cost of property
taxes and so to me there's always going
to be another thing another fear and
that's why i asked where do you want to
live and if you want to pay cash for a
house that's awesome i love that goal
for you guys especially at your age not
having to worry about a mortgage payment
do you guys have anything in retirement
we have close to a half a million in
retirement okay awesome and what's your
household income
it is
i wrote it down
it's about oh my gosh i don't know where
i treat it my husband's here we have a
little over 120 000 in um death crows
our net is closer to 85 000. sure and
it'll probably go up if you move away
from california so that's nice but
here's the thing you guys are close to
millionaires if you're not already
yeah that's awesome have you taken a
moment to celebrate that because a lot
of people are fearful and they have
right to be but you guys are
millionaires you have a great income
you're very healthy you're willing to
work i mean if it's anything like mom
you guys could go past a hundred you
still got another 40 years of your life
so i want you to have a vision for it
and it doesn't have to happen tomorrow i
know you're sick of renting but i don't
want you to sit around renting for the
next 10 years because you want to pay
cash for the house i want you to move
forward with your life
uh regardless of that so here's what
here's what i want to see you do anna i
want you to take out that handsome
husband of yours and i want you all to
go y'all go right here uh he's right
there sitting right here with me i want
you to he's not that handsome is he just
kidding he is so i want you to take his
hand and i want you all to go have
breakfast i want you to plan a two or
three hour breakfast together or a nice
lunch or dinner whatever y'all do and i
want you to ask each other the question
we've got 20 years we've got 30 years if
we're looking at mom who's 103 we may
have 40 more years to go
what do we want to do with the last few
precious years of our life
what do we what jobs do we want where do
we want to live what do we want to have
access to
what do we want that to look like and i
want you all to dream together to answer
your original original question i would
not
be looking at homes until i had a place
to work and i wouldn't in your situation
be so focused on what the job is going
to be until i know where i want to look
and concentrate that or maybe we're
going to look at that in dallas and in
florida george you nailed it there's
always going to be a thing that's going
to trip this up you're a millionaire
anna
a millionaire
y'all did it you're doing great
turn this thing around dream big and
then
find a place where you want to be find
work and then work on getting the home
thank you so so much for the call give
us a call at
825-5225 we'll be right back on the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsay show i'm john
delonie joined by george campbell we are
taking your calls on mental health
relationships money
your mortgages what in the world are we
doing in 2022 anything you got going on
in your heart and mind triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's go to mindy in
birmingham alabama hey what's up mindy
hi thanks for taking my call thank you
for calling what's up
yeah okay
so
um
i'm in a situation where
we've worked really really hard for a
long time in school and
saving and everything that we have
quite a bit of savings we have uh or
just money that has
um
that we have i guess earned um
i hope that's how you got the money yes
400 uh to 500
in cash right now and we are wondering
um
we were planning on putting it in the
stock market you know investing it
but the other day i started a couple
weeks ago i started listening to your
show
and i thought
i you know i turned my husband and said
maybe we should pay off our house
and he said you know well our house
our house
to pay off our house would cost about as
much as it would cost to pay off our
business loans
and he's like that's not a
our business loan is has a higher
interest rate
and
i was kind of like oh well i'd rather
put our money if we're going to do that
i'd rather just put our money into
investments
and so now we kind of have three
options
because we have we have no
since we're self-employed we do not have
any um
you know match program or
any retirement program right now
and so
i was just calling to ask what you would
do
um
as far as where we should put
what's the best use of this money what's
your business and
um it's an orthodontic practice
and um you all are billionaires aren't
you
billionaires
no
no no
but we have for a long time he's been
working for seven eight years now
we have four kids and we've paid off
three hundred thousand dollars of
student loans
we bought you know another practice that
we ended up
you know going back to zero as far as
our bank account is to you know um go in
with
to this you know another about another
practice and so we feel like
i kind of i'm sitting here feeling like
we have no retirement when he thinks you
know well we have a couple businesses
and that's just where we've put it we
haven't
you know or my family kind of grew up
telling you put it in the stock markets
in the stock market and he's kind of
more likely
how long did it take for you guys to get
this 4 500 000
um a couple of years you're going to be
okay
so here's what i want to say
breathe exhale
well
it's also you know you never know how
your business is going to go i mean sure
yeah we've had a great couple of years
but you know is it going to say
let me simplify economy going down i try
if i'm talking to my wife and she's
sending a text she's not hearing me it's
really hard to do multiple things at
once and right now you're trying to do
three things at once and you're feeling
the tension in the middle of all of this
and so if i'm in your shoes here's what
i'm doing the business loan is not on
the same playing field as your mortgage
you guys are in debt right this this
loan is under your name so this is like
baby step two we're taking a side step
here
so if i'm in your shoes i'm paying off
this loan which is going to free up a
whole bunch of money isn't it
um which one what's the debt service on
your business loan on this business line
you said it's science they're both about
the same they're both right so our house
we probably have about 300 000 left
which is
our house is on a 15 year and um it's
like 2.3 percent and then the business
loan is a little more it's closer to
400.
because he actually just renovated um
the office so
anyway but that's not like a
4.5 and he's saying like he he told me
yesterday he's paying a little over 4
000 a month for that and
um like 26 is going towards comfortable
sure i'm not as concerned with interest
rate right now
through a different filter where i'm
going all right let's pay off this
business loan that's going to free up a
lot of cash flow and then we're going to
start investing 15 of your income into
retirement that might look like a sep
ira or a solo 401k you guys got to get
that set up for yourselves as
self-employed folks and then beyond the
15
you're gonna have so much margin to
throw at the house and pay this thing
off within a few years
so we can do all three but we can't do
it at once
right so
so another thing that's going through
our minds is that you know that stock
the stocks aren't down right now
is this a good time to invest it's a
great time every day is a great day to
invest if the stock market's down you're
getting the stocks on sale that's right
and if they're going up right your
stocks are going up with it and so i
don't want you to try to time the market
here you just need to be consistently
investing over time let me give you a
framework i want you to keep in mind
okay
you're trying to solve for safety
and you're trying to solve for freedom
and you're trying to solve for growth
you can't solve for growth and freedom
or you can't solve for growth when
you're not free
and you can't be free if you're not safe
and you've got a 400 000
liability in a business loan hanging out
over your head
right right right so let's solve for
safety there and let's be safe let's get
that out of the way
then let's solve for freedom
we owe
let's say your last name is smith the
smiths owe nobody anything
no business debt no house debt and then
suddenly
i just freed up an extra eight thousand
dollars a month in business loan
payments and house note
for put dumping into retirement now
we're solving for growth
here i'm going
yeah so let's be safe right let's be
safe oh that's what it was john what we
just had to admit so my husband's right
oh no
resignation in that tone oh what's his
name no i'm good don yep he's not listen
he doesn't even know i'm calling so well
when we email him after this call and we
clip it and send him the video he for
sure will but you you're asking great
questions here's what's cool george
mindy and her and her husband
they've already been living these
principles they have a 15-year note they
are paying off their student i mean
they're way down the road yeah right so
now it's just a matter of getting these
things in the right order yeah and mindy
i want you to run this business
debt-free once this loan is paid off
because that's going to take all the
fear out of the equation it's going to
take is this is going to be a tough year
for us you don't have to worry about
that when you have no payments in the
world on your business and in your
personal life but we have to do these
things in order so that we feel the
progress because otherwise you're going
to be going i'm going to try to pay this
off while paying the house off while
trying to invest in the market and
you're not going to see progress in any
of those areas so you just recently paid
off your house
what was the challenge
i'm like her i want to do everything all
at the same time and if i can't do one
of the three things i quit them all and
i just sit in my house well you know
john a lot of people are they they came
to me said george why are you paying off
your house early you could be investing
in the market
why are you paying down this low
interest debt when you could leverage
that and put it on the market for 10 11
and i just kept thinking to myself i'm
fine because i follow the baby steps i'm
gonna we'll be multi-millionaires so
right now my goal is not to try to get
rich quick in the market my goal is i'm
solving for freedom right now yeah i'm
trying to increase my cash flow so that
you know our greatest wealth building
tools are income right and until you
have that freed up it you can't really
do all the things at once that's right
and now that we don't have a payment in
the world we can go all in on investing
and generosity and we have time for all
these things and so that's what i want
from mindy i mean they're a young sharp
couple running an amazing business
making great money but she didn't feel
that you don't feel that in her tone
that she's doing great everyone in
america
there's fear there yeah you guys are
making hundreds of thousands of dollars
a year and you feel this tension of
we're not doing enough right so you i
don't blo i don't want to blow pi by
something here real quick before we go
to break you mentioned hey this business
debt y'all set this up in your name this
is really like a huge credit card bill
people don't see business debt as their
debt kind of like well student loans
isn't debt right or yeah business debt's
not debt
but it's it's don and mindy llc you know
orthodontist practice it's your debt
and so you've got to get rid of this
thing run your business debt-free that's
what we teach in entre leadership and
mindy i'd love to send you a copy of
that hang on jenna's going to pick up
read through that book you guys are
crushing it and i want you to continue
to crush it
eight two five five two two five we're
talking about everything right here on
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
on the debt free stage
tracy from sioux falls south dakota how
in the world are you
really really good really good so good
to see you and your friends and your
matching t-shirts you fit perfectly here
in nashville
is this like a bachelorette party what's
going on here no this is my debt free
screen party oh thank goodness y'all
didn't come here on a pedal tavern
that's fantastic all right so you're
here to do your debt-free screen yes
walk us through it how much have you
paid off i have paid off 98 000.
how long did it take
about four and a half years four and a
half years and how much money was your
annual what was your annual income um i
went from about 45 000 to about 58 000.
and what's your profession well now i am
in in it
but before i owned my own business i've
always had you know three or four jobs
my whole life but i was a college coach
i owned my own business um did
accounting i'm an accounting major
so i had several things that i was doing
now since i've become debt-free in june
i sold my business i was catapulted to
step baby step seven
and i've been able to quit a lot of
those wow you get to be a human again
yep so what kind of debt was this
it was everything from student loans to
irs to
family loans to
um i mean anything you can imagine
credit cards
uh doctor bills
everything
so what happened four years ago
that caused you to say enough is enough
is enough
there was a couple of different things
one of the major turnarounds in my life
was when my son and i had gone to one of
his hockey tournaments and i had gone up
to the hotel to pay the hotel bill and
my credit card was denied and so i
pulled out another credit card that one
was denied um i called a couple of my
friends to see if they could and nobody
would answer
during this time while i'm standing
there at the desk several people from my
community are coming up and seeing this
and
it only i was only able to get a room by
my dad faxing over
a form saying that he would take care of
my hotel bill so that was that was the
first thing like okay something's got to
change
and then at four and a half years ago
i was just at the time where i was going
to do
a debt consolidation
and i remember talking to the gal on the
phone and she's like
you know just quit paying on everything
we'll take care of it for you
and and i remember thinking i got a
really sick feeling in my stomach
because i'm like but these are my debts
i should be paying for these
they're not the responsibility of
anybody else and about that exact same
time my sister was
signed up to do
well she signed up to do the
financial piece within our church fusion
church fusion church in mitchell south
dakota and so um
she said you know what tracy before you
do that debt consolidation because like
i was about ready to sign you know and
she said before you do that look look at
dave ramsey look at this and see what it
ever since then i've just
i've been gazelle intense man wow it's
incredible
so what was the hardest part about this
journey
probably the hardest part was just you
know of course telling people no
but after i got comfortable with telling
people the journey that i was on and not
really caring about their reaction
because really the
you know everybody out there thinks that
you have to have a car payment
you have to have a credit card you know
all of this and i was proving them wrong
i was
i was proving them wrong it can be done
and you can do it so i think probably
just saying no and that's probably let's
pray about it so what did you do to get
out of debt
um
i hustled like a maniac like you're
already kind of a hustler maniac yeah
like i look at my planner from two years
ago and
there's no room like i was everywhere
doing everything you know whatever so
now i can relax
so you went from you've got these maxed
out credit cards that are being declined
what were you feeling during that moment
and now what do you feel after this
transformation
um
i was feeling beat down and i was
feeling like
i have been believing everything
people have been telling me all this
time and my parents were great with
money and i have there's five siblings
and we i mean we worked from the day you
know from 14 years on i've always had
two or three jobs so it wasn't part of
that um
but
i'm sorry i forgot the question oh i was
just wondering the feeling the emotion
from like the shame of like oh my gosh
i'm in front of all these people and i
my cards are getting declined left and
right
and now the freedom that you have what
was that transformation like emotionally
and you know that day we went back to
the hotel room and i just started
bawling and my little my little boy he
was like mommy it's okay it's okay it's
okay
and i tell you what when
you guys tell us
that
this is freedom that this is peace i am
telling you it is it there is
i'm just shaking there's no other
feeling like it what other things were
going on in your life because that's
usually when money is in that situation
when you're sitting at a hotel
counter trying to get in
the rest of our lives are a mess too and
this is just the big neon sign saying
we're in the ditch
i was single i was i had two kids i was
waiting i literally was waiting for
somebody else
to
make it better i was i thought somebody
was going to come into my life
and
i wouldn't have to work i wouldn't have
to worry i and it's like why was i
ever okay with thinking that and feeling
that it's just it's such empowerment and
i can see that that that woman four and
a half years ago was not real happy with
what she saw in the mirror and this
tracy
you love tracy enough to get matching
t-shirts that's all i'm saying right so
who are your biggest cheerleaders right
there these are my biggest cheerleaders
my sister theresa is
like i said she's now a smartvestor pro
as well as leading financial peace
university
but my niece kelsey my daughter taylor
my friend nikki and my friend kelly they
kelly and nikki are both debt-free my
sister's on her way she's almost there
and our two girls are living it too
they're seeing us do it so that's
incredible what do the shirts say for
everyone listening um it says from the
605 to the 615. so a south dakota area
code nashville area code nice and then
on the back it says ask me why i'm on my
way to nashville and then it's got
hashtag 605 baby steppers oh that's
awesome you have a gang
yeah we have a gang so you don't know
this but the cool thing in nashville is
to get the hashtags on your shirt
tattooed on your body so you all can do
that after this we've actually thought
about that we've actually thought about
it don't listen to him do not of course
you you have we're so proud of you yeah
we're so proud of you thank you so much
you are strong and brave and you did
hard things and you've changed it
not just your family tree you've led the
charge and all of these folks family
trees are different because of the work
you put in and i'm grateful to have
people like you in the communities that
my little kids are growing up in because
that kind of bravery that's going to get
us out of this mess and you did it and
i'm so grateful for it thank you so much
we got tracy from sioux falls south
dakota paid off 98 000
in four and a half years
all by herself working a million jobs
count it down let's hear your debt free
scream
three
two
one i'm
[Applause]
oh my goodness
that might have been one of my top five
screams ever ever
and uh what john forgot to mention is
we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for tracy oh well played
that is absolutely the next chapter in
her story and of course a copy of total
money makeover so that she can ignite
someone else's journey to bravery and
hard things and sacrifice and winning
with money and freedom and all of that
good stuff here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna give you a copy of total
money makeover each to each one of your
your your gang
and the goal is to give it away and
bless somebody else so you're going to
run across somebody in the next few
weeks it's going to be struggling you're
going to say i got the key and it's
going to be hard and it's going to take
a few years and you're going to change
everything good for you guys i'm so
proud of you i'm so proud of you george
that transformation
i did
she's a great storyteller thinking about
being at the counter yeah
and not having the money to pay for a
kid's like soccer stay you know what i
mean yeah
and being able to stand up in front of
millions of people and say i am
absolutely free that transformation
happened because she put the work in she
followed the plan she kept going she
surrounded herself with great people and
kept going kept going from the 605 all
the way to nashville so grateful for you
wow change can happen right here on the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
it's resolution season and if you're
like most people you make resolutions on
new year's day and give them up by
valentine's day why
because you are trying to figure it out
on your own
so if you've decided to take control of
your money this year don't do it alone
get the support and accountability you
need by joining a financial peace
university class you'll go through our
proven money plan with other people who
will help you stay motivated because
they're trying to get out of debt and
build wealth just like you
right now there are hundreds of fpu
classes getting started both in person
and online welcome to the 21st century
so forget the lame resolutions make 2022
the year you take control of your money
and don't do it by yourself
find an fpu class and get started for
free at
ramseysolutions.com fpu that's
ramseysolutions.comfpu
let's go to robert in richmond richmond
virginia what's up robert
hey how are you all today hey my brother
how are you
just fine
uh before i ask my question i wanted to
congratulate george and his wife on
paying off their house oh thanks so much
that's very kind
uh well my question is about retiring
earlier than i had planned
um i'm 61 years old
uh my husband is 67 and
she was recently diagnosed with early
stage alzheimer's
i'm sorry i planned to retire at 65 but
now i'm thinking
i i may have to uh either go part-time
or fully retire earlier than that
why would you need to retire early
well
right now
uh he's he's fully functional but i
don't know how long he will be
because
you know with the dementia and
alzheimer's you can't predict a timeline
yeah it's a it's an absolute
demon i want to take a second and just
say i'm so sorry that's so so hard
um walk us through your financial
picture here
i hate i hate that this is a part of the
conversation but you know it is right
it's part of it everyone's giving me
all this advice on caring for someone
with dementia but it's the financial
right there's a reality to it yeah
it's reality
uh well
uh we're debt-free including our home
awesome
uh currently
our household income is about a hundred
and six thousand
is that combined income or just yours
that's combined that includes his social
security okay
uh
we have retirement account
that's worth about 930 000
how much is your house worth
uh
about to
250 to 275 range so i'm talking to a
millionaire right
yeah i'm a every uh everyday millionaire
very cool yes our baby steps billionaire
yes
baby step millionaire there you go
so um so if you reduce your
if you reduce your income and go to half
what's that going to do to your overall
take-home pay
let's see
i was
to go part-time to
from 36 to 24 hours a week
would uh
reduce my
my take home income to about 57 000 okay
a year and what's his social security
total
uh his social security
27 33 something like that
his social security if i calculated it
correctly is 6 900 a year
oh okay
that's lord um okay the reason
you know one of my hesitations about
leaving
the workforce is my insurance because i
you know i don't qualify for medicare
for a few more years right
so is is he on your is he on your
insurance plan
no he's not he's already on medicare
okay okay i have insurance to my
employer which if i
if i go to part-time i can still
maintain
my employer sponsored insurance okay
so what what do you think care looks
like in the near future
through through medicare
what i'm sorry what does that care look
like long term because right now
everyone's at home
but you're you're saying do i need to
stay home and and help take care
of him is that the situation yeah
because right now there's a lot of
unknowns it sounds like there's nothing
interesting
and
you know part of the issue is i've i've
always worked tonight i'm a nurse i've
always worked night shift
and i'm sure you know you know that
with dementia
a lot of a lot of people with dementia
are fine during the day but as the
evening progresses and they get tired
they start to become confused
how much
how much of this is already happening
and how much of this is a year two years
an in an indefinite number of years down
the road
um you just forget for once in a while
you know he'll misplace things or forget
he has appointments
um you know he's still able to drive
go shopping
just you know normal everyday things so
it sounds like robert the
the question you're wrestling with is
do i want to make do i feel a need to
make sure
i get the most time
as as long as we've got it
yeah
or because the money part sounds like
you're clear i mean the money sounds
like you can pay your bills you got a
million dollars in the bank you got a
paid for house you're gonna you know
once you social security you can drop
down financially especially once you are
in medicare years and your insurance is
taken care of that you sound like you're
good there sounds like a question of do
i want to keep working am i going to
feel guilty about missing time is there
is you get what i'm getting i'm headed
yes
yes and that's a big thing for me is
um
i'd like us to have
you know
sometime
together while he's still you know
reasonably cognitive okay sure
i mean yes i'm going to
stay home and take care of them when he
declines but i'd like to see i have a
few good years together before that
happens and
could you switch to a nation to do in
retirement yeah is there is there things
you can do professionally so here's some
things i'd love you to dig into
professionally i'd love to dig in and
see if
you can go to day shift for a season can
you try the part-time gig for a while
see how that goes financially see how
that goes
at home and at work and then if it
doesn't work you can swing back sounds
like as a nurse who's been doing this a
long time you've got a lot of options
the the big thing here is number one i'm
never going to tell somebody george i'm
never going to tell somebody
work over relationship work over a
family work over time time is finite
right it goes
the other side of it is as we talked
about there's a financial reality to
some of these decisions
it looks like robert you all have put
yourself in a position for just a moment
as this
but i don't want you to project things
that might happen in two years in three
years in five years and seven years
onto your
present reality because right now things
are pretty good still it is wise to be
making decisions and planning for the
future but right now things are okay and
i don't want you to miss the moments now
or make professional decisions now for
things that might happen in the future
right yeah that's exactly what i was
thinking of i don't want to make
decisions based on what ifs and maybes
and five years from now we'll cross that
bridge when we get there and the good
news is the financial part i mean
robert's done so well financially
following the baby steps that the
money's not really a stressful part of
the equation right now right it's more
about the relational aspect of okay and
retiring early at 61 he's ready to
retire if he wanted to yeah he's a
healthy guy he could keep working
we need nurses out there but oh god we
need nurses like you mentioned her he's
got options and that changes the
situation and so if you were if you were
young and you're listening to this
those options
that robert at 61 is is is
is looking at
started years ago right started with
little decisions made years ago to
retire to pay off your house and to do
things
so robert will be thinking about you
brother um that's it for this hour of
the ramsay show will be back soon we
hope to talk to you all right here on
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
we talk about money your life your
mental health your relationships all of
it i'm john doloni joined here by my
good friend george campbell and we are
taking your calls at
825
522
and we are waiting for you to give us a
shout the phone lines are open and the
call is free and the advice is worth
about that much hundred thousand dollars
easily i'm gonna go with free okay let's
go to geo in phoenix arizona hey geo
what's going on
hey how's it going guys thank you very
much for taking my call and i really
appreciate that guys you got it brother
what's up
so basically i'm calling index i'm
planning to open a pool company i have
heard dave ramsey say that we can't get
supposed to acquire a company without
having the financial backing but
basically working the product out or
working the business out with the owner
and then trying to pay it off that way
um what i'm calling is how would i get
more clarity on how would i go about it
to get to that one point that i want to
be and what processes do i need to do as
well too
so let me get this straight you want to
buy a business
yeah so basically i want to buy a
business or a pool route and basically
instead of paying cash for it i've heard
dave ramsey say that you could basically
say hey you know instead of paying
attention you can kind of work that one
area down to pay down the debt or
basically not including debt of any kind
basically so it's more like hey i'll buy
this business for 200 000 and i'll pay
you
twenty thousand dollars a year for ten
years
out of the profits yes is that what
you're saying not necessarily going with
a two hundred dollar mark you know
something more smaller that's a little
bit more plausible per se yeah sure so
what kind of money are we talking here
what's this business going to cost
so basically i'm trying to see if i
could invest maybe about five to 10
grams or maybe i want to say maybe would
be 20 to 30 pools if anything but wanted
to see how could i structure it so i
don't get in debt and that would be a
little bit more successful as well too
well why i'm curious why do you want to
buy a business versus just starting your
own pool business
uh just because the ease of the process
uh since i do the school business now as
far as uh with another company i've
noticed that when you're out there and
you're kind of uh communicating with the
customer they kind of it's a lot more
difficult to kind of start something off
the ground when it's a little bit
smaller versus once they see the bigger
numbers so they hear the bigger numbers
and that's where i'm kind of getting
stuck in the situation saying hey uh i
feel like i need to get the business in
order to get the little customers but
then also i don't know if i'm even going
the right way about it with all this
question well not the question but
that's just the understanding of the
situation yeah geo i i don't buy that
um i i buy you i don't buy
what you're being told
okay because
there's gonna be big market players
right you're gonna have the i don't know
who the big pool guy is in your town or
the who the big
the big pool company is
but there's gonna be people who
interface with geo and you do an
incredible job
you come in under budget and on time
you are respectful you clean up the area
when you get done you write a thank you
note you send flowers
people will make sure that message gets
out it will be slower
but that message will get out
and often what debt allows us to do is
shortcut that process and try to
leapfrog our way to the front of the
pack
and
i get what you're
i get
are you stru let me are you struggling
to find gigs
are you struggling to drum up business
what is that um i can get the gigs but
when uh communicating the customer the
value or the worth of the product that
i'm trying to give to them that's what
i'm kind of struggling because uh the
prices that i'm leaving out pretty high
due to the demand of it but the
communication that i'm having is that
i'm not making it worth the price that
i'm charging and that's what i'm kind of
getting messed up in the head saying do
i need to get a bigger business or you
can be bigger or how should i rethink
about this whole thing to kind of be
more successful now that you're beating
it up that way yeah
no i would much rather you sit down with
somebody who's going to help you and
i've had to do this here okay i'm
passionate about mental health i'm
passionate about relationship i'm
passionate about people
living good lives
i've also spent the last 20 years with
nerds with academics we sit around and
we talk about theories and we discuss
things and practitioners and what works
and what doesn't and in that over the
last 20 years i've developed a language
that i use and i found when i came to
ramsey solutions that that language
doesn't make sense to somebody who
doesn't live in that world
and so i've got folks that i've sat with
and met with that say okay you're trying
to say this
say it like that here's a way to
communicate this to the marketplace so
i'd much rather ins
before you go buy a a brand name just
because you don't think you're big
enough or you don't think you're good
enough
i want you to sit down with i'd rather
you pay somebody to help you with your
marketing message help you with your
story arc of what am i trying to bring
to somebody
what how do i build a portfolio so that
when i give somebody a price i also give
them four references and pictures of
before and after and i show up
professionally and i don't um
whatever it is right and i don't even
fully understand the pool of business
but
what i'm saying is i don't want you to
sell yourself short just because there's
a disconnect between how good you are
what you're doing and the way the
customer is hearing it right now going
into debt isn't going to solve that
problem that makes sense awesome that
was my fear uh and then who would i be
talking to in this type of environment
would i be talking to uh like some type
of i'm not an investor but somebody that
does deal with business but what section
of the business would i be talking
because that's where i also get
close-minded yeah
go ahead you just need to get good at
sales and marketing and so we've got
resources for you through entre
leadership entre leadership elite is our
membership program our friend donald
miller has some great books on story
brand and marketing made simple you
gotta learn some things i don't think
this is a should i buy a business or not
if i'm gonna buy a pool i'm gonna go to
geo for five grand or the big business
for five grand i don't see any more
value because it's a bigger name i'm
just looking at the numbers here and so
you can start this business on your own
and move slow like john's talking about
do it without debt get better at sales
and marketing and then you own it
instead of owing some other guy for the
next 10 years and realize i don't even
want to do this anymore i i i want to
see you stay on the line geo we're going
to send you a copy of andre leadership
book just the art of building a business
and it's not a theory book it's a
step-by-step playbook also want you to
go to donald miller's website and check
out his story brand book he's got a new
book out called hero's journey that
walks you through what kind of life
you're on a mission here on a mission
that's right here on a mission and
um dave's friend he's in new york
sure the marketing guru seth goes
big fan of seth go read everything by
seth godin brilliant and he'll walk you
through marketing a b and c most
importantly how to tell your story to
the marketplace so they can hear you
yeah right all right let's go to doug in
kansas city hey doug what's up brother
hey guys what's going on
i've got a uh
a 13 year old uh two-door sports car
that i've had paid off for about a
decade
but i've got a 10 month old that's
getting hard to fit in here and i'm
planning on having another one which
would make this car completely unusable
and so i went looking for cars and the
used cars are outrageous so i'm
wondering
should i tough this out until i have
another one and hope the car prices go
back to normal or should i just get a
new car
so doug i'd say george you and i are
both the same same same boat here um
i've got a used car that i took to a
shop yesterday and or two days ago they
gave me a quote and it's high
and i'm having the car repaired
i did buy my wife a gently used car a
few weeks ago a few months ago and it
was really expensive but we had the cash
but i'm choosing to repair my used car
that's pretty dang old right now and i'm
going to wait till the prices come back
down so that's what i'm doing in my life
yeah all right we'll be right back on
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over eight hundred dollars
a year go to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
825-5225 hey george real quick on that
last call i know it sounded like i
wasn't paying attention to what he was
calling about and i tried to tell him
what i was doing with my life and i want
to make sure everybody connects the dots
here because my wife tells me sometimes
my story's not a good doc connection i
don't land all the planes she i launched
well you shouldn't drive multiple planes
at once john that's your first problem i
know but there's a lot of cool parts of
stories we just always land them all
right so the gentleman called and said
he's got a two-door car i think he said
he had a two-door sports car right his
kids having a hard time getting into it
right in and out and do we just buy the
car buy a new something new right now or
do we hang on
and i used my analogy if i got an old
car man it's old and it needs some
repairs and i went ahead and paid
normally i wouldn't have paid as much as
i'm paying for the repairs but the
market's bonkers right now right and so
what i was trying to get at is i'd ride
it out the car works you're able to get
where you're going it is uncomfortable
getting in and out it's a pain
roll your eyes about it make some jokes
about it actually
come up with some sort of um you know
metric or something so your child can
see you saving money for the next car
they can be a part of that process and
then man wait for the wait for the car
prices to go back down to things running
yeah it's not an emergency and when i
look at emergencies i go is it urgent is
it necessary is it unexpected and this
one may be necessary but the urgency and
the you know is it unexpected no you can
ride this out it's uncomfortable yeah
it's annoying it's safe yeah nothing's
gonna go wrong here and so this used car
market there's no deals to be had and
you're paying over market price and you
know who knows six months from now a
year from now things might calm down or
you just save up and go all right we've
had enough we've saved up enough we're
just gonna buy a car even though it's
not a great price right because we need
it there you go and so that's what i
would do if i was in his shoes keep
saving and if you really really get sick
of it and you're in a good spot to just
buy a car outright then do it there you
go all right let's blinds.com's 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsey to get the best deal rules and
restrictions apply today's question
comes from michelle in south carolina
she says my 17 year old grandson was
removed from an emotionally and
physically abusive home he's now in our
care prior to being removed his father
would keep all of the money my grandson
earned at his job now he's worried about
saving his money in the bank because he
doesn't trust not having his money in
his hand what is the best way for us to
teach him how to handle his money
so michelle
first and foremost thank you for being
the kind of grandparents that will take
in an abused
grandson
that's hard and it's a challenge a 17
year old grandson that's been
emotionally physically abused um
is needs somebody that loves him deeply
and will walk alongside him
so it's easy to look at this this kind
of question george
what and ask it as a money question it's
a tactics question
what i see here is a young man who's
who has been bathed in trauma his whole
life right whether it's neglect whether
it's physical and emotional abuse
whether it is
any sort of parental addiction any any
number of things this kid's been through
it
and so his understanding of what is safe
and what is
um quote unquote the right thing and
smart it was completely wiped out
because
the people who were supposed the two
people that he was supposed to be able
to count on mom and dad didn't show up
and in fact they didn't show up they
heard him right and so we're talking
when we talk about this kind of fear
this kind of trust challenges
we're talking about
amygdala we're talking about safety is
this kid needs to learn how to feel safe
in his own body he needs to learn how to
feel safe with the people around him and
this is a long healing journey right
i want to focus on man
this is going to sound tr i want to
focus on getting this kid great trauma
counseling
i want to focus on
if if he can if he's um willing to
accept it a lot of physical contact
right holding hands going for walks
looking him in the eye
hugs
talking listening right we're talking
about basic
physiological safety here
if you want to teach him about money
i would focus not on conversations not
on more words and tactics
i would have him sit at the table with
you while you and your husband do your
budget right i would have him go to the
bank with you and instead of you doing
online banking for a year i want you to
go to the bank and take them with you
and meet the bankers sit in a bank or
office and get new check i mean we're
talking going old school here but we are
teaching him safety we're not teaching
him money tactics right and he's going
to need a new picture for how to do
things this is bigger than just can i
trust a bank this is can i trust anyone
can i trust my body can i trust myself
right because the
the core trust that we have is that mom
and dad will love us and show up for us
and his didn't right and so again i want
to circle back michelle and say you are
a saint and an angel so is your husband
i'm so grateful that you all are
stepping in this young boy's life he
needs some good trauma counseling he's
going to need to relearn how to feel
safe in his body
and he's going to need new pictures of
what safety looks like of what good
choices look like he's been talked to
probably his whole life he needs some
pictures and you guys walking alongside
him as he learns what a bank even does
what he learns what a trustworthy adult
even looks like
that's going to be the way you turn this
thing around and then at the very end of
that we can talk about how your money's
safer in a bank than under your mattress
right exactly the house catches on fire
your money's gone and the fdic the
federal deposit insurance corporation
they've got you covered up to 250 grand
per person per account right that's the
nerdy stuff but like you're saying john
we can't just spit those facts in him
right now and make him feel safe with
his money that's right that's not the
problem in fact it will work against you
right then your body alarms will sound a
little bit louder sometimes
all right let's go to harrison in
atlanta georgia hey harrison what's
going on
hey guys i'm doing good how are y'all
outstanding what's up
all right so i've got a quick question
here so
not this past sunday but the sunday
before
i was on baby step three but somebody
ran a red light and totaled my car oh no
kind of
yeah it wiped out my emergency fund
and uh
i'm kind of just struggling to figure
out
where to go from here are you okay
yeah i'm all right um just you know i
was just really sore afterward but
yeah so what happened with the emergency
fund where where did that money go
towards did you have insurance because
it sounds like it was their fault and
their insurance should pay all of your
all the bills here right
well the there was no witnesses and the
police report said no one is at fault or
he couldn't put anyone particularly at
fault because he didn't he wasn't there
to see it happen
did you just have liability coverage on
your car
yeah okay okay
so
george speaking here
i'm gonna tell you something that's not
gonna feel great
um but hopefully in good time you'll see
that it was that it is
this is exactly why you have an
emergency fund
for this moment for emergencies
and it's
really hard when you have worked and
clawed and scratched and finally filled
up an emergency fund and it becomes a
badge of honor right george i mean you
don't want to touch that yeah you flex
it's like yeah that's what's up that's
the foundation i'm leaning on and we
forget that it's designed for this exact
moment when somebody runs a red light
and smokes your car and you got to go
get something otherwise the alternative
here let's go to alt reality
you are at a some dealership buying an
overpriced car with a car note right you
would have had to go get a loan if you
hadn't have already put this work in
and so harrison i i'm suggesting man
this sucks this is hard
and good for you brother you set
yourself up for just this moment and i
want you to
exhale and be like yeah it's true and
then you got to go back to the bottom
and start over and start saving your
money again yeah so what's your car
situation now
well i've got a um a relative of mine
had a
vehicle that wasn't running and they
said basically
i can drive it as long as i need it if i
get it fixed so i've got everything
fixed on it and i should get it uh
saturday i bet you look pretty cool in
this thing what is it
it's a 98 toyota camry oh you do not
look cool in that
i retract myself
that thing will run forever that's what
this calls about you're not mad about
your uh you're not heartbroken about
your emergency fund you're just
heartbroken about driving an old camry
dude get that emergency fund back in
place get the right insurance in place
get a dash cam for your car even on the
camrys this never happens again and then
save up and upgrade your car over time
that's what i would do if i was in your
shoes i in fact just got a dash cam a
few weeks ago john i love it i feel so
safe i want nothing to do with dash cams
the world does not need to know how
john's a privacy nerd
i love it
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying thousand dollars about two
years after that i got a remote job that
pays me a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars all thanks to what i learned at
bethel tech you could be next get
started today at
betheltech.net and get 1000 to twenty
five hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you've ever gone through a life
emergency you weren't prepared for
financially
that definitely includes me you know
that sick to your stomach sweaty palms
feeling all too well as a parent you
hope your child never has to go through
an experience like that but teaching
teenagers how to be smart with money
before they make dumb mistakes like we
did can feel like a big job
you don't have to resort to the school
of hard knocks to teach your kids about
money
with our digital self-study courses your
teen will learn the right way to handle
money no matter what curve balls life
may throw at them down the road and the
best part no instructor needed if your
teen has a tablet or a computer they're
all set to start learning how to budget
save and invest even how to write a
resume or start their own business
before i invested in my kids business or
buy them a car or help them buy a car
i'm going to make them take this course
parents get your kids off to a great
financial start and go to
ramseysolutions.com
self study to learn more about all of
the different courses we have available
for your middle or high school kit
fantastic all the parents said amen
exactly that's exactly right
crystal in colorado springs what's up
crystal
hey george and john how are you
phenomenal how are you good
i had a
mutual fund question my husband and i
have
a mutual fund that is not a retirement
account it's got about thirteen thousand
dollars in it
and we aren't sure if we should leave it
alone or if we should put it towards our
house or roll it to our kids college
funds okay so you guys are in baby step
456 right now
yep awesome
well what's the conversation like do one
of you want one thing and the other one
wants another
nope we're kind of
uh good with any decision we have 97 000
left to pay on the house we're
anticipating we'll be done with that in
two years so it would speed it up maybe
about
i don't know three or four months so
it's not like a major
one way or the other it's just kind of
uh
how many of you how many kids and how
old
they're uh six and eight six and eight
and are you currently on track are you
funding that college fund and you feel
good about it
we're funding it right now
there's not a whole lot in each of them
we're mostly focusing on the house we
want to get that out of the way and then
kind of well here's the thing i i think
this through and i go okay if i attack
the house and the house is gone in two
years that frees us up to save a whole
lot for the next 10 years before they go
to college right
right
so that's my thinking i free up that
house payment and now we can go full
throttle and make sure the kids are
taken care of for college and maybe
they'll get some scholarships they can
cash flow some of this work a little bit
so i'm i'm more on the boat of paying
down the house and speeding that process
up knowing the kids are young if the
kids were like 16 17 and there wasn't
much going i'd say let's let's put this
in there and help them go to college
debt free but it sounds like that's
going to happen because of their age
gotcha and crystal here's one more thing
to think through i've met with i can't
even count on thousands of college
students and their parents over the
years
and
the most common thing i hear is my kid
was dead set on this
and now we're looking at that
or i thought my kid was gonna be
interested in this and now they're
interested in that
i can guarantee you how old do your kids
sit one more time
six and eight yes
the higher education
market everything about higher education
is shifting morphing turning and so what
it's going to look like in 10 years
nobody knows and i've got a six-year-old
too i'm in this exact same boat what i
do have in front of me is a mortgage
that is a known known right
and so i want to clear that up
and then we will begin to invest we're
going to be responsible so we're going
to put money away all that kind of stuff
like georgia's talking about
but i know this thing's in front of me
and i have no idea what my kid is going
to be like in 10 years
yep that makes sense and i would love to
be done with the house sooner oh later
get done cash it out hey george how good
does it feel so good john i can't i
can't stress it enough if you are able
to pay off your house do it oh although
we did just get another dog and so that
it feels like another mortgage payment
that's worse than a mortgage payment
that's true
i will say that's a whole other show i'm
gonna get myself in trouble let's go to
andy in salt lake city what's up brother
andy how are you doing
hey guys doing well uh better than i
deserve really so what's up
so i'll give you the question then you
guys can ask me for filling so
basically i want to know my wife and i
are trying to decide do we take twelve
thousand dollars out of what is a cash
e-fund in our account to put to backfill
roth iras that we're just opening up
these new roth iras to backfill those
for last year and then we'll start doing
monthly or do we cash out to an
employee's stock pay the taxes on that
and use that money to backfill those
roth iras and then we'll continue with
our monthly investment i have a little
hard time hearing you tell me where that
12 000 is coming from again
so we've got cash in the bank we've got
uh 28 thousand dollars in an emergency
fund cash in the bank exactly
my goal is to rob that of 12 000 and put
it back to the roth iras because i think
it's a little more emergency money than
we need my wife strongly disagrees she's
uh disagrees about the emergency fund
amount
about pulling the twelve thousand
dollars out of that to fund the roth ira
well what it what is a proper emergency
fund that you both agree on is the right
amount
be honest with you we've been floating
you know the three to six months thing
right now we're closer to the six months
end
um i think she's really comfortable
there i'm less concerned
but
that's my thing it's more about are you
guys on the same page because you could
i would tell you you know to take that
money out first if you're not going to
drain the emergency fund but it sounds
like that's going to put her in an
uncomfortable position
it will uh i yeah she's very
uncomfortable with it so that no i look
at it that should be the end of the
conversation i know my option at this
point twelve thousand dollars for safety
and security in my wife's heart is a
that's a that's a kmart blue light
special deal brother
i could give everybody's
spouse safety and peace for 12 grand
dude i would i would i'm going to cash
out the employee stock yes as or just
chill out why are you so
so frantic about backfilling a roth like
it feels like you like are you worried
about missing something
uh just the interest we've we have done
a good job of maintaining our family and
maintaining our budget keeping our debt
down but we haven't done a great job of
investing i'm 42 years old you know i
got about 25 years or so and and i want
to be able to
you know have i just want to be in a
good comfortable position i'm not
looking to like transfer a ton of wealth
or anything but i do want to live a
comfortable life cover medical things
like that and we have not done it we
know we haven't done a good enough job
on retirement so i'm looking to maximize
now yeah well you're not going to miss
the stocks and to have those roth iras
growing for you for the next 20 years
that's that's i'm good with that but i
don't want you draining the emergency
fund at the expense of your wife having
a security gland flare up and now we're
in another fight yeah because of that
and i'm going to tell you andy i already
got plenty of those yeah i'm i am
i am more along your wife's i i'm i want
a bigger emergency fund six months is
minimum for me that's a light thing
because i spent most of my career
working
in situations that don't normally happen
to people and most of my day was made up
in the situations i know the wheels fall
off i've been doing that forever
so i'm i'm with her i
a bigger emergency fund makes me feel
safe
what i george you call it out andy what
i want you guys to do planning for
retirement planning for what life is
going to look like 25 years 30 years
from now and reverse engineering that
only starts with you guys getting in a
room and dreaming together envisioning
this thing together not envisioning in
some let's make a mood board or whatever
but
what do we want this thing to look like
and we throw this part out dude and i
know it's not cool because like bro
forget all that
how is it going to feel when we get
there
it's cool to say like i want to live my
life on the beach you're going to do
that for 30 days you're going to be
bored and sunburned and broke right what
is it going to feel like whenever we get
to wherever wherever it is we want to go
and reverse let that be part of the
equation here right and safety is key
right safety is key especially 12 grand
man come on if if now i've heard this uh
my wife says we have to have or my
husband says we have to have
uh
f350
like super extended thing for the safety
man and it's 130 000 and because we got
to get the roush package wrong no
you're trying to justify bro behavior i
won't have that on this show i will not
there you go but 12 000 bucks in an
emergency fund so that your wife can
sleep brother that is a bad that's not
paranoia that's that's reality that's
real
[Music]
let's go to thomas in raleigh north
carolina hey thomas what's going on
[Music]
hey guys thanks for taking my call
what's up
hey so um
i guess
somebody's all right question in the
simplest terms is what's the best way
that i can save money in kind of the
medium term
for
a down payment on a house or to purchase
a house and i guess more specifically
how can i hide that money for myself so
i don't feel inclined to spend it that's
a great self-aware question
how do i stop myself from plunging into
my own savings that i'm working really
hard for so uh thomas are you debt free
i am yes and you've got your fully
funded emergency fund of three to six
months
yes we do okay
so what is the timeline for this house
purchase
see and i think that's part of the
problem is that i don't really have a a
timeline there's there's no pressure at
all that's even better the financial
problems that i've uh encountered in my
life i i learned the hard way but i
learned them really quickly and because
there's not really like a learning
moment here for me i feel like that's
maybe why i'm struggling but you are
wise beyond your years you you just said
there's no pressure and that to me is
the key here
if you're not under some urgent timeline
that's usually just a justified excuse
of why we have to get a house this year
uh so how much do you have saved
currently
uh including like all my liquid savings
or just don't touch the emergency fund
how much do you have outside of that
uh i think right now there's only about
sixty five hundred dollars okay
and have you looked at homes in the area
that you want to live and what it might
take to get a reasonable home there
nope because we're also not exactly sure
where we want to go when i finish school
ah
okay well here's what i would do uh are
you look could you wait three years to
get a house or more oh we're planning on
probably waiting five or six years
beautiful okay i like this a lot because
i want you to graduate while you save up
slowly take your time with this because
you don't even know where you're gonna
live
and what the house will cost but you can
just stack up a whole bunch of cash in
the meantime
so thomas can can we get real personal
for a second
absolutely it's between me you
george and america and a couple million
people
so what does spending give you
uh usually food
no
you're out of control with it
you you get something from it
what does it give you
i find myself usually i spend money on
things that add a level of convenience
to my life and like i know that usually
whenever i
uh do overspend or we collectively my
wife and i overspend it usually is going
out to eat or something like that just
because i just we just don't want to go
home and cook or you know whatever the
case might be
so i think it's just that at that level
of convenience it's usually services and
things of that nature okay so we're not
talking about a pathology here we're not
talking about you have a clinical
diagnostic you have a clinical issue
with being able to control your behavior
this is a question of intentionality
you just don't
what's the old quote if you don't have a
if you don't have a goal that you're
aiming for you'll get there every time
if you aim at nothing you'll hit it
every time there you go way better when
i say yeah yeah that was well done so
here's what i really want you guys to do
and i feel like i'm i'm a resounding
gong i say the same thing over and over
and over again
but i want you and your wife how long
have you all been married
uh six years okay i want you all to go
out together
whether it's like my wife and i like we
like to do breakfast we both wake up
early and our minds are still clear in
the morning
go spend a couple or two or three hours
together and do an inventory like here's
the last six years we've been at school
been running around we've paid some
stuff off but here's kind of where we
are
and then take inventory of where you are
do you still like me
do i still like you of course you do but
here's where we are and then spend the
bulk of your time if you don't sabotage
yourself with that second question as
the bulk of your spend the bulk of your
time
where do we want to be
and you and your wife need to come away
with three or five or seven value
statements here's who we are and here's
what it's going to take to get there and
one of those value statements might be
we are going to be home owners and have
no mortgage debt in 10 years and so back
feeling like
walking backwards or no actually a value
statement will be we are homeowners we
are people who have roots in a community
and what does that mean we need to buy a
house what does that mean we got to
start saving our money you've got to
have some goals and some some some
identities with which you are
directing your actions toward
does that make sense
it does it sounds like you are tired and
relatively aimless and you have a bunch
of like that'd be cool and we want to do
this we want to do that you haven't
written anything down you've got no way
to hold you or her accountable and vice
versa because you haven't taken the time
to put stuff in concrete and say let's
go do that do do this
i i agree with that statement okay
thomas let me put you put a picture to
this and tell you exactly what me and my
wife did we started off our marriage
debt-free and we decided we want to put
as much down on our first home as
possible so we kept saving like crazy
people for our first year of marriage
while renting and we were able to put
down 45
on our home
which then allowed us to pay it off in
26 months and so that's part of what you
need to start driving towards it's like
john is saying is have that goal say we
want to save up
a hundred thousand dollars over the next
three years how are we gonna do that
we're gonna buckle down on the budget
which means we're not gonna spend over
here we're not gonna eat out as much
we're gonna enjoy our lives a little bit
but we're really focused on this goal is
that when i get out of school and we're
working our income goes up man we're
gonna go full throttle we're gonna be
able to put 25 30 down on this house and
so you start to really make this reality
you start driving towards that and you
guys are going to do amazing things but
like john's saying you've got to get
focused on this thing so that's that's
what we did john and
for saving down a down payment i'll tell
you this if it's going to be three to
five years thomas you can park that in
index funds so that your money can grow
a little bit there you go that's what we
did and it helped us a little bit to see
that money grow you feel like you're
making extra progress thanks to compound
interest now if it's under that if
you're looking at a two year three year
time horizon i would park it in a high
yield savings account and it's gonna
make you know pennies on the dollar and
you deal with it and that's fine but
it's at least parked outside of your
normal bank account that's what i don't
want you said it yourself i don't want
to be able to touch this thing so i like
having it in a separate bank with a
separate company altogether
so that you're less likely to do that
but you set that goal of a hundred
thousand dollars and say all right three
years what's that take 33 000
per year what's that going to take this
much per month what's our income how
much can we put towards this thing and
start to set a real goal on paper and
use that budget to drive you towards
that
i
i think underneath it and again i'm i'm
ripping this off from james clear i've
nev i've never heard it outlined this
way and i love it
beneath you and your wife's goal
was a decision that as a as a value an
identity of our of our home of our
marriage of who we're going to be
is that we're going to do
hard things together we're going to
unify we are unified in setting hard
goals and we go get them right and so
something about getting with your spouse
getting with anybody in your life that
you do life with and saying
who are we gonna be
and then let's go get that stuff because
most of us start with a goal and we
don't have an identity that backs that
goal up we just have a bunch of tasks
and you end up spinning your wheels why
am i even doing this let's just order
extra appetizers and get
another round and then let's do another
round and all of a sudden you've blown
through your month's food budget on one
meal because you it wasn't about value
it's just about some knickknacks and is
right i see it a lot of time people try
to lose weight it becomes obsessively
about this number on a scale not about a
person who's trying to be a steward of
their body or someone who wants to be
able to roll around with their grandkids
right value statements does that make
sense yeah and it's driving towards a
bigger vision than well my wife wants me
to lose weight so i guess i should lose
weight instead it's man i'd love to be
able to play with my grandkids outside
yes that would be awesome i'd love to
take an extra mile on my walks in the
evenings with my husband i'd rather you
know it it it becomes about so much more
right or i'm a guy
who takes good care of the one precious
body i have
that's a good place to start any sort of
life change yeah i'm a guy that loves my
grandkids who i haven't even met yet so
much that i'm going to take care of my
knees and hips now so that i can wrestle
in 30 years that kind of value statement
an identity statement is deep that's
huge and with home ownership a lot of
times there's outside pressure it's well
my dad says i should be in the house by
now because i'm 32. right and when he
was my age he already had his house paid
you know there's all these outside
pressures and when you start to peel it
back and go identity based it changes
your motivation and then you get
somebody like thomas who's not even done
with school and he's already like i
don't know where we're gonna live i
gotta get a house i can't i can't not
spend that money
yeah put these steps in the right order
do them one at a time and start with who
am i going to be who are we going to be
it's another hour of the books good job
george you're getting better i'm just
kidding that's so much better
i feel like i'm making this thing up on
the fly thanks to james childs and ben
hill and jenna sierras we'll be right
back on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your relationships your
mental health your money anything and
everything we're here for you i'm john
deloney joined by my good friend george
campbell and we are taking your calls on
pretty much anything at
825-5225
give us a buzz and we will help you out
the best we can the call is free and
that's about what the advice is worth so
let's go to kayla in indianapolis
indiana what's up kayla how are you
doing
hi guys how are you
great what's up
so
hopefully you guys don't shred me too
hard for this oh you're your friend
i know
so
we did the right thing we sold our car
that we were making payments on we sold
it to carvana
and they gave us about 8 200 and then we
put that towards another used car a
beater as they would call it
so we ended up spending about 5 800 out
the door on this nissan armada it looked
great on the outside we had test driven
it and it was doing all right um except
the check engine light was on my husband
asked about it and the guy said it was a
battery and he could get it off so
i drove at home it drove a little you
know like a used car and so we called
about it the next morning
and it wouldn't even start so we called
the guy he said take it to a mechanic
and he would work out a deal with us on
getting it fixed that sounds officiated
but my husband's like okay so we took it
to the mechanic
turns out the subframe is completely
ruined there's a hole in the exhaust
pipe that's leaking water onto the
subframe making it even worse just
terrible to drive unsafe
um and he's just told us it's completely
toast so my husband went into the
dealership today
talked to them and he laughed him out of
the dealership basically do we have any
room to sue them i mean what can we do
like i'm putting my trust in god fully
and i i know it's going to be all right
but i'm i'm a little serious and i want
to see if we have any room to do
anything about this
okay so
there's no way we're gonna shred you
over this okay this this stinks i'm
sorry
yeah we're out about 5800 bucks the guy
told us he inspected it and he told us
he didn't my husband recorded him saying
he did get it inspected but he couldn't
find the inspection report somehow
so you can go to small claims court
you can sue them and
i can't give you legal advice but you
can contact a lawyer in your local area
and good on that road if you'd like to
okay um i would recommend adding up or
getting some really clear
um
written
right you've learned the importance of
that
clear
written um a written contract about what
legal advice is going to cost what going
to small claims court would look like
what settling would look like
i don't know what the
recording laws are in indianapolis is it
a one-party state or two-party right
it is a one-party statement okay okay so
all that to say is you can go down that
road
it's not
maybe he gets a letter a demand letter
from an attorney and he writes you a
check and gives you your money back
maybe that's what happens
probably not that's what i've read
usually
would happen if he were found to be in
the wrong probably not
okay
um
let me just say if i'm you yes i i've
got buddies who are attorneys i worked
at law school for years so i would have
somebody write a letter and i'd pay them
and they'd write a letter and see what
happens there
um okay
i also would be prepared both
spiritually and psychologically and
emotionally
for this to be a painful 5 800
lesson
yeah that um we
we you knew driving that car off the
line that something wasn't right in it
and it was a big car and armadas are
cool and they're big and we got a good
deal on it and
now you know
i'm never driving a car off the lot with
a check engine light on i'm never
driving a car off the lot without an
inspection in my hand i'm never right so
you learned all these things and if you
look on the uh on the arc of your life
how old are you
uh i'm gonna be 30 in september okay in
10 years 15 years 20 years
5 800 for the lesson you've learned here
because this is going to impact how you
buy a house it's going to impact how
how your kids go to college it's going
to impact everything because you learned
a hard lesson here
and everyone i know has made them dave's
made them with millions right you've
made one with fifty eight hundred
dollars this will be a lesson that pays
for itself over and over and over again
i don't want you to beat yourself up
over this okay yeah i'm kind of i know
you are
you know cried out yeah because this
sucks we we we only have 2 200 in our
savings because we're in financial peace
right now yes
and you know we and you and your husband
y'all are good people you would never do
this to somebody
and you just ran into a scumbag an
absolute
cheater scumbag who ripped off a young
family and it hurts because you don't
even know people like that
and often when you run into someone
who's just a scumbag like this and
you've heard me say this probably before
yeah you lose trust in other people but
more importantly and more damaging you
lose trust in that beautiful brilliant
person that you see in the mirror every
morning
okay
yeah and it's a 5800 lesson and it sucks
and it hurts and hopefully you can find
a lawyer you got somebody at your church
to write you a letter and maybe this
person coughs up your money and it's all
over and you learn that lesson too
but i don't want you to lose trust in
yourself this hurts and this is hard but
you will work through this and i know
y'all are busting it so hard ah the
stings man
kayla i'm so sorry you're going through
this it makes me mad yeah i'm pissed for
you um
and i would definitely push
on this dealership to to make this thing
right and do all the things that john
said that was really really well said
but a lot of this stuff is going to be
well the contract says as is and when we
sign that thing this is what we got and
so like john said we're not here to beat
you up we love you and i just want to
help you move forward and make sure that
you guys have a car to drive are you in
a situation where you don't have a car
now
so my husband has a car but we have a
toddler and an infant i'm on the turkey
leave right now i have to get my toddler
to school at nine my husband has to be
at work he's a general manager
of a hilton so he has to be there to
open the doors and or to manage all his
employees early in the morning
then he would have to come back home get
my son take him to school then go back
to work and it just interferes with a
bunch of things so we were trying to get
another car yeah you guys have a church
community right now
we do yeah we're in a wonderful church i
i would get plugged in with them i would
talk to one of the you know pastoral
care folks over there and say hey here's
our situation is there someone who would
just let us borrow a car while we get on
our feet or would sell us one for a
thousand dollars a beat her to get us
around just to get through the situation
that's one of those things where having
a community like that can be so so
powerful to walk with you through this
journey
and i know that's humbling and that's
hard and that's annoying and you did
this thing right kayla you did it right
you sold your car you were going to pay
off some debt i know
that's what sucks is i i know i did it
right and i and i got taken advantage of
you did y'all got y'all got burned and
you didn't listen to yourself are you
ever going to make this mistake again
you know i told my husband
i said i don't like that that is in my
phone and i don't like how he answered
that question and he's like whoa he said
it could either be 50 50 chance so i
mean i should have just dressed in my
god
always always trust your gut trust
always kayla is trustworthy kayla is
trustworthy
this scumbag used car salesman selling
cars being like nah bro it's cool is not
trust your gut and don't trust check
engine lights ever ever
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to jamie in springfield
illinois what is up jamie
hey
how are you good how are you
good um so i have an issue that i wanted
like an external opinion on i've got a
bunch of them so let's try it we are
external
you go first um
so i
have i live in a rental and i've lived
here for i'm right at the end of my year
lease
my landlord told me sunday that she
needs to move back in here um i have
until march to find somewhere
the problem is i have exhausted every
possible rental option within like an
hour of my workplace and there is
nothing
so like
nothing or there is nothing nothing like
i have asked everybody i know
they have asked everybody they know i
have looked everywhere on the internet
there is nothing it's a very rural area
that i'm in and so options is
implemented anyways and i also have two
dogs so it makes it really hard to find
anything
and to top that off i'm like right at
the beginning of baby step two so buying
isn't an option so i have two options
um my boyfriend has offered for me to
move in there
but i feel like he's not really ready
and i think he offered because he feels
kind of obligated
um every time i try to talk to him about
it he doesn't really want to talk about
it like i try to figure out the
logistics and he doesn't really want to
talk about it my other option is i move
six hours south to where my parents my
grandma are
they
really want me to do that they're more
than happy to help me get on my feet on
the ground there and what do you do for
a little issue with that i so i work um
for a hog production company which is
the other thing i make really good money
right now better than i'll probably make
anywhere down there you make calls
i i work for a pork production company
so i uh
and probably my boyfriend to move down
there so i'm kind of scared okay let's
let's address these in order okay and
george please hop in any moment
um
number one did you just hear the last
call
i did not okay
um thanks for listening and paying
attention to the show i'm just kidding
all right so here's the deal here's the
deal she's working john the call ended
with us telling a woman who's about to
be 30 how old are you
i am 24. okay 24. you all are same
age-ish
she did not trust her gut
and she bought a car that she she knew
uh something not right about this
and her husband was like nah it's cool
and the used car seat was like nah it's
cool she didn't trust her gut
you know that moving in with your
boyfriend is stupid
you know that right
yeah yes okay so for the sake of your
relationship for your mental health for
any sort of downstream trauma that's
gonna come from this let's take that off
the table for just a second okay you
know that that i understand getting
desperate and trying to figure things
out and let's let's fast forward i get
that let's take it off the table for a
second
do you like where you live right now
i mean
not really like i don't really
i'm not really attached to where i live
and i don't enjoy my job like the money
i make is awesome but i'm not really
like attached to anything here except
for my boyfriend
what and he's not really attached to you
by the way
so i know what's six hours away
so
my parents live in southern missouri
like right on the arkansas border my
parents my grandma are all down there
and my niece
your voice changes when you talk about
moving there
it's subtle but there's something about
what is it about there
that lights you up a little bit
i guess my family
so i don't see a way around
this what i'm about to say
either any way you slice this you have a
couple of hard decisions to make
is it time at 24 to go live with family
for a season
is it time to just keep plowing away at
a job that i hate that i'm going to look
up and be 48 and be like what did i do i
just made a bunch of hogs i don't even
know how you do that by the way
are you going gonna keep running around
with a boyfriend that is not nearly as
into you as you are into him
i or
there's no way to not have a hard
decision to make here
so anytime i'm faced with a series of
not great options and i got to make some
hard calls i'm always going to go back
to my values who am i and what am i
about and what do i actually want to do
with my one tiny precious little life
and what i'm hearing in a three-minute
phone call is that you want to go be
around your family
and we'll figure out the job we'll
figure out the housings we'll figure
that stuff out
and that you know the situation with
your boyfriend is rough you know you're
making hogs and making good money but
you don't you don't like it you you get
what i'm saying
yeah jamie how much money do you make
i make like 39 000 a year god almighty
on a stick jamie i thought you were i
thought you made five hundred thousand
dollars
you can make thirty thousand dollars
that's what i was getting at you can
make that and live closer to your
parents you can switch careers it's not
too late you're 24 years old
you could work for another 40 years you
could have 17 different careers i've had
17 different careers
inside this building inside the building
so jamie i feel like you've backed
yourself into this corner that isn't
really a corner
but in your mind you're stuck with no
options either i move six hours away or
i live with the pigs right like there's
there's more options than that
and it feels like you've exhausted it
because you're tired
and you don't want to be in the
situation and you want things to be
better but truthfully if you found
another place to live your life still
wouldn't be great
so can i can i reframe this for you
jamie
yes there's some remarkable research out
about
stress
and mindset around stress
um andrew huberman's put out some some
great stuff recently on this idea of
stress and the way we approach it
and
there is some
significant benefit
to receiving a stressful situation like
your landlord coming home or coming and
saying hey i'm giving you your 30-day
notice i need my place back
if you look at that as an opportunity as
a 24 year old
hard-working
resilient brilliant young woman to say
oh awesome i didn't like this job anyway
i don't even like where i live
i get to go have an adventure now or you
look at the stress of that 30-day notice
as my life is trapped
there is a physiological consequence to
that it stresses your body out but
there's something bigger than that
there's opportunity cost one way and
opportunity lost on the other
i want you to spend some time with you
and nothing else but at you in a journal
okay and i want you to write down what
an adventure could look like what would
my life look like i want you to begin to
see this in pictures not just words i
want you to see them in pictures and
write this stuff down draw it out
i'm get super nerdy like we're middle
schoolers again and i want you to
imagine life in missouri and say
does this bring me peace can i start a
career there can i get plugged back in
with my family can i find things that i
want to do maybe go back to school and
learn a new like i've done my years with
the hogs now it's time to go right
i want you to spend some time saying
what do i actually want and that's gonna
frame whether you have to have a hard
conversation with your boyfriend or
whether you double down your search
because no i'm staying with the hogs i
love my community i'm gonna stay here
you get where i'm headed
yeah
and my gut tells me this is way way more
about boyfriend than housing am i right
i guess i mean there really isn't
anything to rent but that was more the
issue i guess than
housing yeah
housing sounds annoying the boyfriend
sounds existential how long have you all
been dating
uh a year okay yeah that's hard man
because you kind of made plans didn't
you you had some plans
yeah yeah that's so hard i'm so sorry
that's hard hard hard
we are 100 in your corner jamie
don't don't
don't quit your job before you got a
place to live and don't don't race off
and do anything rash i want you to spend
some time thinking this out for me for
the folks i work with writing this stuff
down getting it out of your head whether
it's in a journal or on a word document
i don't care a notes app on your phone i
don't care get it out of your head and
look at it and begin to ask yourself
what do i want to do right yeah all
right let's go to alex in st petersburg
florida uh are we gonna run up against
the clock yeah we're running against the
clock i don't want to do that um
that's good john self-awareness i'm
learning here james is very happy and
there we go hey it's time to put 2021
behind us last oh no we're even coming
up on the music one day hey listen
listeners you can't catch a break john
no i can i just need to get better at
this this all i'm working on i'm gonna
get there i'm here for you all right so
we get back we're gonna take more calls
and i'm gonna read this all in the same
segment i believe in you thank you
teamwork somebody does somebody does
we'll be right back on the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's time to put 2021 behind us
last year left a lot of people feeling
burned out and sluggish eeyore was their
spirit animal but 2022 is a fresh start
and this is your wake-up call if you're
ready to own this year and actually
accomplish your goals with money your
career your life we have to plan to get
you there
you can make 2022 your best year yet
we're running our new year's sale right
now so you can get up to 73 percent off
our best-selling books assessments and
envelopes that includes my brand new
book our dave's brand new book baby
steps millionaires that will show you
the quickest right way to become a
millionaire or if you're looking for a
better way to manage your cash
especially in categories that always
blow up your budget like food pick up
our popular essential cash envelope
systems maybe you're having a hard time
bouncing back from the last two wild
years you should start 2022 with my
best-selling quick read redefining
anxiety to learn what anxiety is what
it's not and how to get your life back
and here's the deal it's only 10 bucks
so visit the online store at
ramseysolutions.com
backslash store to get serious and make
real progress but hurry the sale ends
soon
good stuff john so before we go to some
calls here our most excellent producer
james childs uh sent us this article
that is fascinating from forbes here's
the title if there's no student loan
cancellation student debt strikes could
be next awesome this is juicy stuff so
senator elizabeth warren has obviously
been pushing for this student loan
cancellation wide scale
but
what if they don't what if it doesn't
work our student debt strikes next that
is the question posed here in this
article i don't know what the strike
would look like is everyone just going
to stop paying and see what happens is
that the goal here i guess the idea is
if enough people just say we're not
paying then we're just going to stop
paying we'll show you
it's an interesting idea uh and it
continues on to say well should you stop
paying your student loans well remember
your student loans are tied to a
promissory note which is a financial
obligation to repay student loans if you
choose to not repay your loans your
credit score could be damaged your wages
could be garnished and you may be
impacted financially they go on with
some alternative options of repayment
plans repayment options applying for
forgiveness considering bankruptcy
pursuing public service loan forgiveness
i don't love these options john right
there there is not a lot of great
options right now
my concern with this george and tell me
what you think about it is
i've you know i've worked in colleges
for my whole career
i know
about student loans intimately right
i've had my own six figures worth of
loans to pay back
the challenge is any sort of
resolution we have whether we say forget
you guys you all got to we got to pay
this all back whether we say hey we're
going to result we're going to as a
country we're just going to say hey this
was a bad deal we're going to wipe ten
thousand we're gonna write fifty
thousand whatever the number is
the
the problem as i see it is so deep
because we don't have a solution for
college next semester what are we gonna
if if biden came out today and just said
no more loans
the kids signing up for for summer
school are right back on the machine
again right and so
we until you solve that problem i
struggle with the solution right it's
like um
i don't know
like i don't have i've only got three
tires on my car and i'm like we gotta
get a fourth tire and then
stop driving first and then let's you
know what i mean like let's put this
tire on so um that may be the worst
analogy ever in the history of analogies
it was a good visual and thank you for
that um that's my problem is that we are
trying to solve this thing out of order
yeah we explored this issue in the
borrowed future documentary which you
were featured in you had some great
things to say dave was featured in it of
course
and it really just points back to this
idea that like we're not
anti-forgiveness and relief we're not
here to keep people hurting but if we
don't stop the source of the hurt then
we're not really helping a lot of people
yeah one of the foundations of my
counselor education was as a counselor
you are constantly helping people out of
the stream every day who have fallen in
at some point you have an ethical
responsibility to go upstream and find
out who keeps shoving people in why do
people keep falling in up here right
yeah
i think that's where we are is we're
sitting down stream and we've got almost
two trillion dollars
worth of people drowning in student loan
debt
we gotta go upriver and stop the problem
up here and then we can be about solving
these downstream challenges yeah we got
to turn off the faucet first because
right now we're just got a bucket and
we're trying to shovel out all the water
while it's still just pouring down and
so that's that's a better analogy than
your tires that's an
infinite well we talk about this
embarrassed future of how this whole
thing came to be and how sallie mae was
actually part of a government entity and
how it all got out of control and it's
so fascinating uh that at the end of the
day the government needs to stop making
the loans if we're going to talk about
forgiveness and i read a flyby statistic
the other day that said just the student
loan pause cost the federal government a
hundred billion dollars last year
a hundred billion dollars and who's
paying for that john all of us are right
ding ding ding all of us so we're
basically saying hey let's relieve the
burden off of us and put it on to our
children and our children's children
and they'll figure it out they'll figure
it out but we want relief now and so i
understand the pain and the anger
towards the student loan system and your
own personal loans in there we yeah we
both have student loans oh man i get it
but here's what i found
a better way to live your life is to
realize that you are in the driver's
seat you can take control you can pay
them off and then you don't have to hope
that a student debt strike works you
don't have to hope that the next
president solves all of your problems
and that is the biggest game changer to
me is realizing that and putting
yourself in the driver's seat instead of
the back seat going well we're going
wherever the driver takes us and i also
am sympathetic to
good grief a young family just trying to
figure out life and they just look at
their budget and they
are both making a pretty good salary for
a starting wage and they can't make the
ends meet like my heart is broken
because i've been there i've paced my
house at night when my wife was asleep
wondering i don't know what bill we're
not gonna pay i don't know how this
works because i was young and i had a
lot of student loan debt so i've been
there too right yeah the whole thing's a
mess and anytime there's a mess in my
world you flip the lights on and you
stop the music and you say all right
let's take inventory what's going on in
this party and then we'll start figuring
out who's got to leave right and i think
we got to start there we got to flip all
the lights on and say we got to solve
the problem way up or do you just burn
it down for the insurance money don't do
that don't do that on that positive note
okay alex in st petersburg florida
what's up alex
hey how you guys doing today great how
are you brother
good good i got uh
a situation more looking for advice so i
have a three-year-old and a one-year-old
and we have our third on the way and
actually my brother-in-law just came
over who's going to be listening so i
just want to say surprise we're having
our third baby
you have a three-year-old a one-year-old
and another one on the way
correct yes
brother
i'm telling you listen
you're gonna sleep again one day it's
gonna be years from now but you're gonna
sleep and it's gonna be great
congratulations man congratulations all
right so what's up
so my wife is a travel nurse now she
just started and
i've been home with the boys so
obviously with her being pregnant we're
trying to decide you know should we buy
a house here because we need to get a
bigger house uh we have about 60k in
debt but it's only student loans and our
two cars so with us traveling what she's
going to be making per week we can pay
it off in no problem so we're just more
we want a home base for us
um you know for us to come back to in
florida because we we plan on traveling
you know maybe across the country even
with the little guys and everything so i
know it's going to be a lot the money we
understand to be life-changing now and
rewarding later
alex hold on hold the phone brother you
just flew by the fact that you have
sixty thousand dollars in student loan
debt and two car loans
no no no that's uh um student loan debt
and including the two cards yeah oh 60k
total
yeah okay it was just very nonchalant
you were just like yeah i mean all we
got is just 60k in debt but other than
that we're fine we're gonna go ahead and
buy and so i just want to pause here
and tell you that you're not in a
position right now to buy a house do you
have any money saved
uh with just the emergency fund i mean
we've been we've been killing it so she
with the travel assignment she recently
started she's making about 4 000 a week
so we're awesome no we're gonna we're
gonna kill it in a short period of time
so that's what leaves me with us
traveling you know once we finish
because there's an end date to the
contract do we come back to you know the
house that we purchase or do we worry
about that once we get home i think you
need to pause man if you need to get rid
of this debt
before you got the emergency fund but
you still got a pile of debt we're doing
things out of order here get rid of the
debt fully fund the emergency fund be
investing save up for the house and do
it when you're financially ready
i know that's hard to hear you got three
kids man but that's that's a tough
situation and i'm not buying a house
while we're on the road nope i'm just
not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture is from romans 15 2.
our goal must be to empower others to do
what is right and good for them and to
bring them to spiritual maturity
john maxwell says power really is a test
of character in the hands of a person of
integrity it is of tremendous benefit in
the hands of a tyrant it causes terrible
destruction
wow i want to read that again because
george is important because power can be
in the if you're the assistant director
of the mail room and you've got four
people
working with you or if you're the
president or if you're elite if you're
in your home power is important
power really is a test of character in
the hands of a person of integrity it is
a tremendous benefit
in the hands of a tyrant it causes
terrible destruction you know what you
could swap that word with
money
yes oh yeah i like that you like that i
like that all right
let's go to edie in tulsa oklahoma
what's up edie
uh-oh i couldn't hear you i can hear you
what's up so can america what's up edie
i have a question for you and i hope i
word it correctly um like so it's
understandable um i have a 22 year old
son
who has wanted to start a business for a
long time
and he wants to take out a loan for
three thousand dollars to start this
business he has never asked me for money
um he wants to take out a loan or use a
credit card because he feels like he'll
get his money back very quickly
um i don't think it's a good idea to be
in debt obviously you guys don't either
at 22 years old i was not in debt and i
feel like it causes anxiety and he
already has that
so would it be smart for me to loan him
the three thousand dollars
or should i just say no it's not a good
idea what's your advice
well i've got my opinions and that is
you should not loan him money and he
should not go into debt and you can't
really tell him what to do so here's the
predicament i agree if i'm you and you
want to support your son
you could gift him 3 000 and knowing he
may never make that money back and this
business could fail because he's 22
years old and he thinks he has it all
figured out this business is going to
crush and so that's there lies the
problem is there's a lot of assumptions
on his part that this business is going
to be great what kind of business is it
um it's a clothing line so he um he's in
music production and he
networks all over the united states he's
on his phone he's on twitter he's on
he's just on every single
avenue and he's
well i wouldn't say that
not not in the negative connotation he
works really hard that's what george is
saying he's a he's he's
a networker oh so he doesn't do anything
he just connects okay gotcha okay
yeah he's a networker but for growing up
introverted
that's pretty awesome i think great so
he's a great networker and he feels like
he has built this base of people that he
talks to that are interested in the
types of things that he wants to create
t-shirts hats different things that
promote
not only what he does so it's his name
of the business he already has an llc
that he went and got last year
um
but i just
you know i i think especially if you
have anxiety you're having panic attacks
you don't need to add money problems to
that and that's what i told him
so one of the cornerstones of helping
with anxiety is connection
somebody sees you and they're walking
alongside you
here's what i would do if i was you
and you can take this and just
use it for two-ply it's just just just a
dude sitting in tennessee this is what i
would do if my kid came to me with this
plan
i would sit down and say
i want to be your number one investor
your chief one and only investor and i'm
going to give you startup seed money
i want to see a business plan and i want
a 24 month guarantee that you will not
borrow money
and so he's going to be able to get 3
000
risk i mean risk-free
from somebody he trusts and this is you
telling him i believe in you i believe
in your business you've shown over the
last year you got llc you're networking
now we're going to see if this thing
pays off but i want to see a business
plan because another thing anxiety is
anxiety-inducing is feeling untethered i
don't really know where i'm going or how
i'm going to get there and it kind of
just builds and builds and builds and
just starts rattling a business plan
gives somebody steps it gives them some
lanes to stay in right and it feels
restrictive but it actually is a gift
for somebody struggling with anxiety
so if you walk and say i'll help you
i'll help you design a business plan
but at the the only stipulation of my
investment money my seed money my gift
to you and i guess investment you're
going to expect to be paid back so this
is seed money this is a gift i like that
is you're going to sign this contract
that you will not take out debt
for 24 months and again george is right
he's 22 years old he do whatever he can
do whatever he wants to and if you're a
mom that's going to sue him over it i
mean it's kind of awesome but
you're probably not going to do that i
love the idea of you being
on the operating board and you're a
shareholder in this thing and then he
may actually come to you for advice
because you're supportive
there's not this weird tension if mom
doesn't want me to do this and she's not
on board but i would also say
you don't need three thousand dollars to
start a clothing line no it's 20 22. you
can do on-demand uh you know drop
shipping where they order the shirt and
then the shirt is made and you didn't
pay for stock and inventory that that
was his original plan and i don't know
why he went away from that that was the
original plan all along he may got a
little starry eyed and found some
equipment some gear some things that he
wants to do that he doesn't have the
money for so here's my thing
if you're going to be a successful
business owner you better know how to
make money and so i would try to prove
that concept first before digging three
grand into this business but if you are
going to do it to support him i love
john's idea of making it seed money and
supporting him along the way and making
sure that he doesn't go into a pile of
debt for a business that very well could
fail all right let's take a one more
call we got we got to get right to it
sally in new york city let's get right
to your question before we run out of
time what's up
yes hi guys i need your opinion on my
current situation i'm relocating from
new york to raleigh north carolina
and
raleigh is the third most
in demand market in the united states
right now the prices are just completely
outrageous i have been looking for a
home for the past 30 days the homes are
overpriced by
a hundred thousand dollars
people are offering
fifteen twenty thousand dollars over the
asking price just to get their home and
their home for staying on the market
maybe a day or two long enough to get
the bids and take the highest bid so i
could hold on i can hear your anger i
can sally i can hear your anger what's
your question i am so angry you know i'm
trying to get out of here and i there's
no end in sight with this this housing
market in raleigh and
there's just no end so i i want your
opinion on should i go ahead and proceed
sally will buy a house move to raleigh
or should i wait into the market um how
much money do you have
i'm sorry how much money do you have to
buy this house
um i'm i'm probably gonna pay uh get
about a 350 000 house between 350 and
400 000.
are you gonna pay cash you can take out
a mortgage no i'm going to take out a
mortgage but i'm going to put down about
50
because i want my mortgage payments to
be very low
and so sally what i hear is that you
have backed yourself into a corner
either i moved to only this place
and only buy a house
or i'm stuck here in hell and i just
gotta ride this out until the end of
time
and whenever we box ourselves into
corners like this we end up making rash
decisions or anger fueled decisions
so what about
exhaling
and then saying what if i move to
raleigh and i just rent and the rent is
overpriced but maybe that adjusts in a
year
and i might be my my down payment on my
house is 40 instead of 50 because i
rented for a year i found it where i
want to live i waited till this market
cooled off or i got some pretty key
indicators it ain't cooling off anywhere
or
i stay in new york and i start to look
at places that might be a little bit
different than raleigh north carolina
they might look the same be in the same
region but i'm not going to go to that
city because it's just too expensive for
my budget and the life i want to live
don't box yourself up into a corner took
the words right out of my mouth john oh
my gosh we're getting better e.t i'm
getting we're connected i love it hey
thanks for thanks for your time george
john awesome great show thank you to ben
hill thank you to jenna sears and of
course kelly daniel in the corner
producer james childs thank you all so
much for listening to the show we'll see
you soon be kind to one another this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world subscribe or follow today
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]